we're gonna leave it there and get into
a story that is important to just about
all of us I would say actually every
single one of us it affects us anyway
it's about money income the cash we all
need to live on remember the fight for
15 it's been around for a decade
National political movement started with
fast food workers right here in New York
they walked off the job demanded a 15
minimum wage well guess what this month
three states actually hit that goal of
15 as their minimum wage
and in recent years a lot of major
companies have voluntarily raised their
pay to 15 or more and it all adds up to
a multi-billion dollar boost for hourly
workers but stay with me in a new book
author Rick wartsman uses the story of
Walmart to argue that all of corporate
America for all of this change is still
paying its workers way less than it
should and the solution he says is
something almost no one is talking about
this is that place where we care for one
another it's one of the biggest stories
in all of business this is that place
where you can grow your career a tale of
reinvention at America's largest private
employer Walmart once the poster company
not only for low prices but low pay
for years unions targeted Walmart with
protests and pointed to worker
testimonials like these Walmart
paychecks simply don't cover rent bills
and groceries I was literally starving
to death people ending up on you know
food stamps and Medicaid and really
struggling Rick wardsman was part of a
team behind a 2003 Pulitzer
prize-winning LA Times investigation of
Walmart detailing alleged Penny pitching
with its own employees
but in more recent years even he and
many others have noticed a shift and I
thought boy there's something
interesting going on you know some
things change and the company welcomed
him in for his new book all about that
change
from 2015 to 2021 in fact Walmart
invested five to six billion dollars in
higher pay increased benefits training
and education and yet this is not the
book Walmart was hoping he'd write just
look at the title still broke did you
wrestle with that one I think the
company still broke after all the change
that is made on this front it hasn't
fixed things yet
to make that case wardsman uses the very
same numbers that Walmart sites with
pride including an average wage that's
now more than 17 dollars an hour higher
than the minimums in every state in
America so what's the problem
well the problem is we've kind of
Forgotten what people actually need to
live on that 17 an hour works out to an
average annual income of just under 29
000 a year at the end of the day after
all this change after all the pushings
and internal conversations and internal
soul-searching that's not a living wage
and the problem he says is far bigger
than just Walmart what this has shown me
just by looking at Walmart is that
Corporate America overall will never go
far enough fast enough on its own the
only solution wardsman says is a federal
intervention a new national minimum wage
of twenty dollars an hour almost triple
the current level we've let things go
for so long and haven't dealt with the
problem
that now we're our backs are against the
wall we don't have time for
incrementalism anymore Walmart's CEO
agrees that at least some increase is
required the federal minimum wage is
lagging behind seven dollars and 25
cents is too low but 20 or even 15 is so
high According to some economists it
could backfire last year for example the
non-partisan Congressional budget office
concluded that raising the minimum to 15
an hour by 2025 would indeed live some
900 000 people out of poverty but would
result in higher prices leading to fewer
sales and resulting in companies
reducing their employment in the end it
estimated 1.4 million Americans would
lose their jobs so the trade-off is yeah
you help a bunch of people make a little
bit more but a whole other bunch of
people are going to be out of a job
entirely and what about them yeah I I
don't buy that they're always going to
be trade-offs there is no perfect
solution to this we've dug ourselves a
hole over 50 years
again we've got to do something Walmart
argues It's Already Done quite a lot in
recent years the bottom line is if
Walmart were not in operation in this
country there would be more people on
public assistance not less Dan Bartlett
is one of the company's top Executives
this is a Walmart Academy something that
didn't even exist if you know five six
seven years ago he wanted to show us a
training facility near the company's
headquarters in Northwest Arkansas where
workers can pick up skills to help them
at Walmart and Beyond what we're
providing to them is enormous amount of
opportunity for them to grow with the
company to make more money and to them
they have to decide then is what is the
wage they need to provide for themselves
or a family we're going to give them an
opportunity to grow but as Walmart
pledges to keep raising pay according to
its website Rick says it already has the
money to do it pointing to the tens of
billions of dollars spent in recent
years buying back its own stock a move
that typically drives up share prices
why not take a fraction of that stock
buyback money and just give people a
more decent living so when we look at
our shareholders who by the way we have
tens of thousands of employees who who
are invested in our own stock and 401k
and those things so they benefit from
those share repurchases as well the
simplistic answer for Rick is that
increasing dramatically the minimum wage
to twenty dollars will solve all these
problems I think is misguided and the
ramifications of there'll be job
destruction I could tell to you today
that if we took overnight all of our
stores in Walmart to twenty dollars
there would be hundreds of stores that
would no longer be profitable so
potential
or do you have to decide to or lay
people off or raise prices
and so you start raising prices you're
hurting communities they're the very
ones you that Rick says he cares most
about maybe so says wartsman but
whatever the trade-offs of a twenty
dollar minimum wage he's sure they would
beat the reality of right now and you
can see that this is going to sound
radical to a lot of people and I have to
admit it does sound like more than is
possible politically you can say twenty
dollars an hour is radical what's
radical to me is to be in the richest
country on Earth and have people who get
up and work hard every Day Struggle to
the degree they are
and there it is and there it is it's
well said I mean it's 40 to 60 million
people by most estimates who get up work
very hard every day and still make
trade-offs at the end of the month
between food and rent you know utilities
and food and it's a hard life let me ask
you something because I know that you do
your research before sitting down with
anybody where does Walmart stand in
comparison to Target or someone like
Amazon I don't know the exact
head-to-heads about those individual
companies but Walmart has made a real
and significant investment in improving
things for its workers and so has much
of corporate America but you see when
you take 17 an hour and you have a 36
hour weekly that's a full-time worker
it's twenty nine thousand dollars people
sitting on their couch at home wherever
you're living ask yourself does twenty
nine thousand dollars get you far and I
think the folks sitting on the couch
look to those CEO and top-tier level
svps EVPs and look at their salaries and
their bonuses and say well maybe those
need to come down and like spread some
of the wealth and it's easy for you know
anyone on the outside to look at Walmart
and say you're highly profitable the
execs are making money Millions
sometimes billions yeah why don't you
spread that money among the people that
work the hardest on a daily basis
because then the the the the stock price
Falls and then you're not raising as
much money you can't make investments
this is the trade-off right if if they
went to 20 they'd have to eliminate some
jobs they say to be profitable and then
someone's minimum wage is not 20. it's
zero dollars because the job doesn't
exist me and they don't agree with that
that economics
as well that was good Tony yeah well
it's really good